for being here. We welcome you to Martin
Middle School. I am the proud principal,
Miss Edna Gortinez, here at uh Martin.
It is my second year. I want to
introduce also my assistant principal,
Mr. Ymo Tabasco.
And we also have some uh distinguished
guests from our district who are going
to start this conversation um for our
community. Okay.
Good morning and thank you everyone for
joining us. Before we dive into the
agenda, I wanted to introduce Miss Dea
Pascal. She is our director of strategic
planning and organizational
effectiveness and she's going to lead us
in an inclusive welcome.
>> Thank you so much. Um I love having a
microphone in the morning when you have
the baritone of just waking up and then
it gets to hum through the crowd on the
microphone. So, thank you so much for
this joy that was unexpected. So, my
name is Staca Pascal as Ally said and
before we begin this meeting, I really
want to take a moment to level set us
and level set us into why we're here.
And so, I invite you to take out your
phone. We all travel with it. It's
probably already in your hand.
And in your phone, I invite you to find
the picture of the person that has
centered your why for being here today.
So find the picture of that person.
There's somebody
that has centered you being here today.
Now for me, it's this lovely young man
right here. He's the class of 2025
graduate from Navaro High School. And
he, thank you. He is my why. So I invite
you to find the picture of your why and
find someone close by and share with
them why is this person your why. Make
sure you introduce yourself as well. So
we'll take about two minutes, find
someone close by, share your why.
Happy
holiday.
That's why
We almost
conducted
All right, you've got about 30 more
seconds. 30 more seconds.
>> All right, I invite you to find a comma.
and then a nice pause
>> because we could go on and on talking
about the heart of our why. They bring
smiles to our faces. They warm our
hearts. They push us to do hard things.
And so as we sit in this meeting, I just
want to reconnect us to our why and how
we work together to ensure that all of
our kiddos have the things that they
need and deserve. So I thank you so much
for engaging with each other. And I'm
going to pass the mic to Ally.
Thank you so much, Staca. So this is our
agenda. We're going to start out. We did
our warm welcome. Um we're going to do
we're going to review our norms and the
purpose of the meeting. Um, we're going
to provide an overview of some of the
campus specific proposed changes in the
consolidation and boundary change plan.
And then we took from the comment card,
the digital comment card, we took the
questions from there and put them on the
slides and we're going to address those
questions first. Um, and then we'll kind
of we can definitely do a back and
forth. If there's follow-up questions or
questions that y'all came with, we want
to make sure we get to those and then
we'll talk about next steps. Um, but
first the meeting norms. Um, we ask
that, and these might be familiar to you
if you participated in the community
conversations that we had virtually.
There's another one coming up on the
27th and on the 8th in person at Delko.
Um, but we want to build the future
together. So, we're going to acknowledge
challenges while also focusing on ideas
that make our district stronger, more
equitable, and sustainable for years to
come. Um, we're going to honor time. So
each speaker, we're going to try to keep
it to about a minute um for a remark so
that and same thing goes for our
responders um so that we can try to get
through everyone's questions. Um honor
each other, speak to one another, not at
one another. Um respect is
non-negotiable. So we are going to ask
that there's no interruptions, personal
texts, and if possible, no side
conversations. We want to honor the
process. So this meeting format allows
for thoughtful responses. Please allow
our leaders to respond without
interruption. Um, but we, like I said,
if there are follow-up questions, we're
happy to have a back and forth. Um,
because we want everyone to leave with a
shared understanding. Um, honor intent
and impact. We may disagree on ideas,
but we assume positive intent and focus
on the shared goals. Strong, equitable
schools for all students. Honor space
and voice. If you've spoken once that we
we ask that you allow others to share
before we would call on you again. We
want to stay solution oriented, focusing
on ideas, solutions, and understanding,
not blame or frustration. And we want to
embrace transparency and empathy. These
are difficult conversations, but we're
going to meet them with compassion,
clarity, and honesty.
Oops. And those are those are the norms
in Spanish for our Spanish speakers.
And our purpose of the meeting. So, we
want to, like I said, we want to make
sure that we respond to some of the
questions that were submitted via the
comment card. That comment card is open
through um the 28th. So, I know that's
next Tuesday. There are QR codes at the
front and over here on the bookshelves.
Um, if you haven't gotten a chance to
submit a comment card, you can do so
more than once. You can comment on more
than one school or idea. So, please feel
free to continue using that. Um, we want
to gain a shared understanding of what
are the actual proposed changes and what
is the district rationale behind them.
Um, and then gain insights from y'all
that will inform potential refinements
to the draft plan. So, we will have a
kind of marked up revised version of the
plan that we will share October 31st.
Um, that is when it will be posted to
the board and shared out with the
community so that the board can then
discuss those revisions at their
November 6th board information session.
And the planned vote is, as a reminder,
is November 20th.
So, with that, um, I'm going to go ahead
and pass it over to one of our
panelists, um, Christine Seamort. Before
I do that, I'm going to just have our
panelists go ahead and introduce
themselves down the line, starting with
our superintendent.
>> Hello everyone. Good morning. Uh my name
is Matias Sigur. I'm the superintendent
for Austin ISD. Uh happy to be here this
morning to have a conversation um answer
any questions that you have and um you
know be as responsive as we can and the
team and I will be for you.
>> Thank you. Good morning. My name is Ibec
Gardanas and I have the honor of serving
multilingual education and early
learning. It's a pleasure to be with you
here today.
>> Good morning. I am Rachel French. I'm
director of planning for the district
and the project manager for the
consolidations process.
>> Good morning everyone. Christine
Steampport, operations officer.
>> Good morning. Jennifer Baker. I'm the
executive director of special education.
Um I'm gonna stand up a little bit and
use the screen. So thank you all. Um so
when we started this effort, it's really
we have we are really looking at the
future. And I know our superintendent.
He wants for this school district is
every family should have access to an
excellent neighborhood school, one that
is vibrant and well resourced. And we've
talked about what wellresourced means.
And um this is one step for us as a
school district to become um a bit more
well resourced throughout this process.
Um
so I want to kind of get right into it
as our proposal. Um, as you know, uh,
part of this draft conso school
consolidation process, um, this would
mean that Martin is proposed to close
and so those students of Martin would
then be reszoned depending on where you
live and I can show up a boundary map
very soon after and it would be students
would be reassigned at Keeling, Lively
and Marshall Middle School based on the
address for the 2627 school year. And so
we have a school finder. it's a little
bit more helpful. It's an interactive
map where you can type in your address
physically and you can see your feeder
pattern. You can see your elementary,
your middle, and your high. Um, I also
want to talk about Marshall Middle
School a little bit because this was a
school that was an assigned campus
before. We had to create a boundary for
Marshall Middle School. So, that's
something new that really for middle
schools took a new section. So, that's
something that we just um recently added
in. So, I wanted to point that out.
So, what does this mean for my school?
Martin Middle School will temporarily
close and students, like I said, would
be res reassigned to those three
schools, Keeling, Lively, and Marshall
based on their address. And, um, I know
you're like, what does this mean? Um,
our board and our administration has
really wanted to see what um, Martin
Middle School could be in the future.
And Superintendent Sigura can talk a
little bit more about that and what that
could be in the future. Um, it could be
another campus. Austin ISD has never had
a K8 uh a K8 model school and so that's
something that could be in the future
and that's something that our board and
the administration will be exploring and
so there will be engagement about that
for the future
and uh more a little bit more about the
plan if you live in that boundary. Uh
again those three schools but um we have
a lot of questions about transfers too
or what happens if you are reszoned. So
if you are a transfer student you can
return to your zone school or apply to
transfer to another campus. So there's
still the options within Austin ISD. So
I wanted to make sure that that was well
known of what could happen if right the
school was prepared to close and then
what the choices are. So um here is the
map. So as you can see here, this is
Martin's boundary here. And so because
of that and the new boundaries for this
m this part in red here, this would be
reszoneed to Keeling. And then this
part, like I said, prior, we've always
had Marshall, but it never had a true
boundary. It was really just a an
assigned school. We had about eight or
nine elementaryaries that were assigned
there. So this was a part of that
process. we had to get Marshall's
boundary in. So, we folded that into
this process and was able to give them a
boundary. Um, and then we have here if
uh if you live within these areas, then
these would be zoned to lively. So, kind
of just wanted to showcase what that
what that looked like.
Okay. And I am going to pass it to Ally
to talk a little bit about what this
would mean for the turnaround plan.
So, one of the things we wanted to share
with y'all is that as you have heard
before, prior to the consolidation plan
releasing, we shared that Martin would
need to have what's called a turnaround
plan, and that was due to the three
years of consecutive unacceptable
ratings that the school had received um
from the state. Um, and so that
turnaround plan, we want to make sure
that you all understand kind of how that
works. So, according to the TEA's rules,
if you if you are choosing to close a
school and reassign students as part of
your turnaround plan strategy, which is
what's proposed for Martin, um the
turnaround plan follows wherever the
majority of students are reassigned. And
so, in our plan, if you remember that
last slide, the biggest school was
Keeling. And that's because the majority
of Martin students will be being
reassigned to Keeling. And so that means
that as we develop this turnaround plan,
if we move forward with this proposal
and our board approves, we would then be
creating a joint turnaround plan that
would be a turnaround plan for the
Keeling Martin um combined school. Um
the appointed principal would then have
the authority to hire teachers and staff
that meet the turnaround plan staffing
criteria employitizing
employees from the two school
communities. So, one of the things we've
developed, our talent strategy
department has developed some guidelines
for how we would staff schools in these
various scenarios where there's a
consolidation that has a turnaround plan
involved or a consolidation that doesn't
have a turnaround plan involved. Um but
one of the things that we have outlined
is that whenever we look at what
percentage of the students are going
from one school to another, we want to
aim to try and make sure that the staff
kind of mirrors that same level. So say
you have 70% and I don't know these
numbers off the top of my head but say
you had 70% Keeling students and 30%
Martin then we would attempt to hire so
that the staff also kind of reflects
that balance so that there's the same
kind of percentage is more or less um
reflected. It's not going to be perfect
math obviously but that's kind of the
goal. um current staff who are not hired
at the turnaround plan campus. So in
this instance it would be um Healing
Martin would be invited to attend
internal um match fairs. Um those will
be in February and March to find a new
position within the district. Our goal
is to make sure that every staff person
that wants to stay with Austin ISD has a
place to land. Um and then the school
the combined school any turnaround any
school that has a turnaround plan. So
that would be Martin and Kealing but
also all the others. Um part of this
consolidation plan is that we would um
free up dollars from these
consolidations and reinvest a large
amount of those into the turnaround plan
schools. Um we're looking at about an
$800,000 investment of extra support for
those schools. Um we have kind of a
proposal within that those staffing
guidelines of what that could look like,
but it will really be customized to each
school. But it can be things like extra
counselors, extra assistant principles,
um instructional coaches or content
interventionists to support instruction,
um parent support. So, they're going to
have that kind of bucket of money to
figure out how do we best invest to meet
the needs of this new combined school
community that's also working on a
turnaround plan.
Thank you.
So, next we we had a few questions from
the comment card. So, we're going to
first start by going through those
questions. And of course, if you have
follow-up questions to these questions,
feel free to raise your hand. We do have
a second mic we can pass around. Um, but
if you'll go to the next slide. Um, the
first question we had was um, what
promises can we get that Martin campus
will be able to reopen in the future and
with input from the community? And this
is from Eric R. That's supposed to be in
Spanish below. I apologize. I'm not sure
how that happened.
So, um, first off, I just want to
acknowledge that this is a, um, a very
harmful moment in this part of the
community. Uh, this, it's not lost on
me. That is a challenging conversation.
So, again, I very much appreciate you
all being here.
You know, we are desperately trying to
address, you know, historical issues
that we've had in our system for well
over a hundred years. Uh, this plan is
complex. It's multi-layered. There are
so many things that impact one another
and ultimately what we're trying to do
is to address a couple things, right? We
want to align feeder patterns and this
is all going to tie back to their
question, but I want you to know these
things. We want to align feeder patterns
in East Austin for over 144 years. For
144 years, we have not had aligned
feeder patterns. We have middle schools
that go to three and four and five high
schools. In other parts of town, that
doesn't happen. You have one middle
school go to one high school. You can
think about how community is kept
intact. You can think about how
programming can be aligned when you have
that type of um of succession planning
and sequencing in our system. We don't
have that in East Sawson. The other
thing this plan attempts to do is to
address uh our response to the
turnaround plans required by the Texas
education agency. So the 2023 24 25
accountability
uh kind of changed how we have to
respond uh to to ensure that we keep the
ability locally to determine how we
educate our students. And so Martin
Middle School is one of the schools that
is required to um submit a turnaround
plan to the Texas Education Agency. And
so this plan accounts for that. I want
y'all to know we didn't arrive at this
plan thinking about that first. we went
through the work and then layered in our
ultimate response to to TEA. The other
thing that it has to address is
consolidations. We are running a deficit
budget. Uh we cannot be at a moment
where we are not able to fund the things
that we have to fund in order to support
um our students no matter where they
are. Uh and right now we're just not on
a pathway to do that. So we have to make
some difficult decisions. The other
thing we wanted to do is wanted to
stabilize programming. We have
programming across this city that is not
uh positioned to be successful for
decibly
our wall-to-wall dual language programs.
Our emerging bilingual student
population in those programs are 14% 21%
22% and 44%. Uh a healthy program is 50%
in time and in the number of students
that are emerging bilingual non-emergent
bilingual. When you think about how the
city's changed, if we don't move and and
create access for those emerging
bilingual students, these programs will
not be sustainable for years to come.
And we know how important they are to
our system. And I would say lastly, our
transfer policies. We have transfer
policies in Austin ISD that have been
doing real harm honestly to our school
system. Uh there are procedurally things
that we do internally that need to be
controlled better. there are things that
we need to really understand and this
plan will also incorporate those. So the
reason I want to bring it back to to
Martin Middle School and why uh
certainty around what the future would
will be is because yes this plan
considers a turnaround plan that has the
majority of students going to keen. We
expect that that will be able to break
the accountability chain. Then reducing
that weight right from our system and in
the timeline in the time that that move
occurs, we will engage with community
and we will build out what the future
for Martin will be. Uh Christine
mentioned uh you know prek through 8.
That's not a done deal, right? We only
put that on our screen because we've
heard from different community members.
We've heard from uh different
stakeholders in the past that going to
an ECA model is something that we should
explore. We collectively will propose
something that aligns with our
community, aligns with the needs of the
system and ultimately brings back
something new to Martin. Uh the
challenge that I that I have is that
there's some certainty that our
community wants and I understand that
but we cannot give that certainty as to
what it will be until we go through that
process. But through this feedback loop
here engaging with you all, you know
what I'm trying to do is to figure out
what language can I use in the plan that
allows our trustees to have confidence
that there will be a school here in the
future and in this timeline. Um, you
know, and that will allow us to figure
out is it programming, is it a different
number of grade levels, uh, is it
something totally different. Um, so the
EC8 or preK8 is an idea. It's not bait.
We have plenty of time to go through
that. Um, I will be honest with you,
this process is not typically a year.
Um, it is usually about two years. Um,
if we're efficient and we're diligent
because you have to figure out, well,
what do we want? You know, what's the
programming going to be like? You have
to hire the principal. They have to hire
their staff. And all of this has to done
with enough runway to actually launch
the school year successfully. And at the
same time, we'll need to work with our
general contracting partners to figure
out what adjustments, if any, maybe not,
need to be considered in the bond
improvement package in order to to kind
of facilitate this new programming. But
I want you to know that the bo I would
say the board and I are committed to
ensuring that there is a AISD public
education
um campus like on this site. Uh but I
have to break the accountability chain.
I just have to break it. Um if not, the
risk is too great. Uh and this is one
solution that works um globally. Uh so
that's the timeline. Um I I know that
some folks would like for us to go
faster, but we just don't that's just
not possible given the complexity of of
building up new a new school.
>> All right, next question.
>> Thank you, Matias. Yeah.
>> Um next question. Um what feeder pattern
will Martin be part of when it's
repurposed? That's Stacy S's question.
Well, yeah. So, when I first read this,
it was I can't we can't answer yet when
it's reopened because we need to work
with you all and what the identity of
that campus might be, right? As the
superintendent just alluded to, and
sorry, I was pulling up the map just to
confirm. Now, when it comes to the
feeder pattern of the schools that are
being reassigned that students are being
reassigned to, um the students that
currently live south of the river that
are being reassigned to Lively would
feed into Travis High School. Um
Keeling, those students um would be
reassigned to East Side. Um and then the
Marshall students um would feed into
LBJ. um for the there's those schools do
have small splits, but I believe that
that is the the new boundaries. Now,
Martin is one of those that currently
I'll feed into I think five high
schools. And so, if you look at it'll
really be based on your specific address
um because all of that is being just
much it'll be much cleaner. So, it's
much easier to kind of look at the new
boundaries versus kind of the existing
Martin boundary when it comes to the
feeder pattern.
Oh, whoops.
Next question. Um, why are you
proposing, and this is not exactly to
Martin, but in the area, why are you
proposing taking two modernized schools
from this community? According to the
proposal, buses would not serve Go
Valley and Sanchez. Can neighborhood
students qualify for transportation to
Sanchez and Go Valley? And before you
respond to that, Matis, I just want to
make sure that everyone's on the same
page. So in this in this O2 area,
Sanchez Elementary is now being proposed
to be a campuswide dual language school.
And so that means it won't have an
attendance zone. Um and then Go Valley
is being proposed to be a campuswide
Montasauri program. Again, those two
schools wouldn't have attendance zones.
Um but we would want students who
currently attend those schools to opt
into those programs. So I'll let you
take that.
>> So um Ally said it well. The one thing I
would say is whenever we were doing the
work, we looked at geographic areas. And
the one thing we know is that
historically whenever it came to
closures, consolidations or any
significant boundary changes, the burden
of that weight in the system was carried
by East Austin. That's just the honest
truth. And so when you think about, you
know, Sanchez, Zavala, Go Valley,
Martin, kind of all the schools in the
area and you look at the number of seats
that we have, we have too many. there
aren't enough students that live in the
area, live in the area, not attendant,
but live in the area. So, we had to get
to a solution that allowed schools not
to close, right? Introduce district-wide
programming and at the same time
preserve uh the historic schools within
uh this area. And so that's why you see
a wall-to-wall program going to Sanchez
that does also break an accountability
chain. Um which again trying to address
multiple things with each of these
solutions. Um Go Valley receiving
Monasuri and again this is all a draft
plan. We're taking feedback but that
would also be a district-wide facility.
And then Sanchez being the neighborhood
school uh allows us to not have to close
another school. Just to be really clear
that's what that allows us to do.
Um I do want to point out that there's
been a feed lots of feedback about could
we provide access to um via
transportation to Sanchez. Uh and the
answer is yes we can. Um we have been
taking feedback from our community and
this feedback I promise you every one of
these comment cards everything that we
hear we are taking it back. We're
testing it. But what I want to be honest
with you about is if I if we look at
this for Sanchez because we want to
provide access to our margin beling
families. We want them to stay at
Sanchez. we desperately do. We also need
to consider, you know, what are we going
to do at Pickle, what are we going to do
at ODM, and what are we going to do at
Wooten, right? Because there's also
wall-to-wall language programs. And so I
want to be consistent. Uh so we are
considering that. Um I think we're very
very close. Obviously, because of
version control, we're not going to kind
of say yes to some things before we can
say yes to a broad set of things that we
receive through feedback. But yes, we
can look at providing transportation. We
have the ability to do that. We are the
system. But I cannot say broadly that um
we can provide it to every student going
through some type of transition. Uh but
for Sanchez certainly hopefully that was
helpful.
>> Next question. Um what happens to the
bond funds allocated to Martin? That's
from Raul L.
>> Yeah. Do you want to go?
>> Hi everybody. Um so right now our bond
funds we are just on pause right now. We
need to make sure we understand what's
happening and we kind of need to look at
our tra trajectory. So, we've got all of
our construction on pause. Um, and to
allude to what Superintendent Sagura
said earlier, we need to understand the
identity and the future of this campus
um to continue that construction. So, um
that's where we are right now with uh
the construction for that. um for the
bond funds that is something that we are
looking at right when when we have a
finalized plan that we want bond dollars
to go with students that is the goal so
we will look at all of our projects as a
whole because it's not just Martin it's
many of our schools in the same
community we have a bond project at
every single Austin ISD school so while
that we can't give a certain answer
right now our goal is to follow with the
school community all of those students
and then also So, we'll see what the
Martin um construction will continue and
look like and those that'll be an
iterative process and we'll keep
everyone informed of what that looks
like.
I just want to make sure that was clear.
So, but that the pro the funding will
stay with Martin. It's just a matter of
what that's going to look like based on
that community process of deciding what
Martin will be.
>> Yeah. So, so this this is a unique
situation because um we are planning on
having a school back at Martin. Uh there
are other schools that are going through
a consolidation or a significant change
and there is not likely to be a school
at that location. So, every school and
every scenario is slightly different,
but I wanted to make that kind of
differentiation and make that comment
specifically to Mark. That's what makes
this one unique.
>> Thank you.
Okay, so that was the last of the
questions that we had prepared. So we
have scheduled this for 90 minutes I
think. What time do we have 10 after? So
I think we have about 50 minutes still
to go. So that at this point we can open
it up to any questions that y'all have
and then we can just kind of go over the
last um next steps. So
anybody have any questions?
>> I'm gonna have you speak into the mic.
>> Thank you. Hi, my name is Tamara. I'm a
parent in the neighborhood. Um, I know
that you said it takes maybe two years
to recraft and start a K through eight
program
and I just have to point out the irony
here that we're like dismantling the
whole school district right now in less
than a year. So, I just want you to
really elaborate more on why this school
couldn't next year turn into a K through
eight.
>> Yeah. So, um, I'm not the only person
that has the authority. It takes the
agency to approve our our plan. Um, and
so what I'll tell you is, you know, in
order for us to start with um a school
in the 206 uh 27 school year, that plan
would have to be submitted to the agency
and the commissioner would have to
approve of that plan uh well before the
school year started, which means that we
would have to hire the principal for the
ECA probably in January. We I know but
the plan has to be approved and and the
plan has to be approved because the way
that schools work is um the agency um
every school has a CDM
>> acronyms
>> uh that acronym I don't know that's a do
you know what CDM
>> it's a campus designation it's it's a
unique code to every
it's a unique identifier to every single
school in the state of Texas um and that
is the thing that accountability gets
tied to that's the thing that the PES
coding for students gets tied to all of
it gets tied to that one specific name
that specific code. Whenever you go
through um a tap and the the the
accountability chain gets tied to
another campus, the agency is kind of
working in tying that accountability
chain to that CDN. Whenever you submit
for a new school, the commissioner has
to approve it. Uh it it is not some that
is
>> correct. So, but you have to he they do
it's not like a simple request. We have
to have a period of engagement. We have
to make sure that um we have the
programming the curriculum is aligned to
the TICS. I mean all the things have to
be built and submitted. And what I'll
tell you is unfortunately being here in
the center of the state of Texas,
everybody is hyper aware of what we're
going through. And if I were to go and
submit a plan, I would almost guarantee
that the response back would be we know
that this is something you want to do is
given all that you're taking on.
Remember, we're still in the tea agreed
order for special education. We are
going through this process now. Uh I I
don't I'm can almost guarantee that he
would not approve it. Um what he will
approve is a thoughtful plan that has
community input uh in the appropriate
timeline. And just to be honest, that's
the time limit I think is is really is
possible.
>> Matias, I think it might also help
because something that I think I've
understood about how TEA works is that
they they want us to get students right
now in the best learning environment
possible. And to them, that is getting
them into a school that's, you know,
that's got good outcomes in terms of the
star. That's and so I think that that's
the other thing that that he doesn't
want us to wait and restart and hope
that that you know is going to serve our
kids better. He wants to see us get them
in the best environments as soon as
possible.
>> Yeah. And and if we were to do that,
that wouldn't negate having to still
make the move. Um and because you we
have, as we said earlier, three
unacceptable ratings. And so if you take
a year um in most years that you start
up a new school, you're still figuring
things out. It's really really difficult
to get it right in the first year. And
so you end up putting um you know
significant amount of risk introduced
into the system because now you're in
year four probably going to have um not
the accountability rating you would
want. Uh and then once you start year
five that's when the commissioner has
the ability to um really turn over the
superintendent and his solid board of
managers. So we really we really need to
clear the um the accountability risk. Uh
that that is something we absolutely
have to do. And I get it's not something
that um we thought we would have to do
in these timelines. The compression of
the 23 24 25 accountability has really
set that. Um and and I I apologize, but
I want to make sure that we all
recognize this is a real risk. There
will be school districts in the next
week, week and a half that get letters
from the agency that they are going to
be taken over. Like this is real. It's
happening across our state. It's not
going away. Um and we got to keep local
control.
>> You were you were first. Do you want to
go? Okay, you'll be next.
>> Um, if they deny one of the turnaround
plans, how does that trigger all of the
other well-crafted part of this plan?
What's the timeline there?
>> Yeah, so um so a couple things. Uh the
timeline is what you submit our
turnaround plans and we're going to
submit ours on the 21st of November. The
board is going to vote on November 20th.
So we submit the next day. uh the agency
has up to 45 days to review and accept
or decline. Uh after the 45 days, if
let's say they decline, then we would
have to submit back a new plan and then
we would have 15 days. At that point, if
a plan wasn't accepted, then the
commissioner could actually move towards
installing a board of managers and u
turning over the superintendent, which
is, you know, that's where you kind of
lose control. Um so I wanted to kind of
give everybody that that timeline.
That's how it works. Which is why it's
really important that whatever we submit
gets acceptable. Uh I said that in the
spring of last year. I'll continue to
say it. Um I am not going to submit
something that I don't have a high
probability of confidence that will be
accepted. Um because of our relationship
with the agency through the special
education order uh the deputy
commissioners and others who are in
charge of much of this work and are
doing the reviews we've been able to
pose different scenarios to them and say
hey you know we are doing something
comprehensive and I think they
appreciate that but because it's
comprehensive there's nuance to it and
say well there's a we don't give them
exact schools we won't say you know we
won't name school but we'll say this
school with this student population is
moving in this sequence we have the tap
going here um
historically this school has had this
rating. You know, how would you respond
to that? Uh we've gone through those
meetings with the agency for the better
part of three or four months just
getting feedback on different scenarios
we could consider and then about two and
a half weeks ago by way of region 13 uh
and the agency we sat down and said,
>> can you explain what region 13 is? So
region 13 is um it is a it's a an
extension of the state um through the
Texas education agency and they're
really like a service center. They are
effectively helping school districts in
a region. Our region is region 13 which
travels from Austin effectively east and
they provide resources to help school
districts navigate the agency. So that's
kind of they're like a like annexes of
the tix education agency. That's a good
way to I'm sorry.
>> Like a consultant
>> like a consultant but they're you know
so that's how it's structured. So we met
with them and we shared with them our
plan for the three UAS and I use UAS
which is unaccount unacceptable
accountability. I don't like using Fs.
Um I don't like using you know all the
things it just three UAS um but there's
three UAS which trigger a tap and we
have two UAS um and there are many of
those total we have 24. So we have to
submit 24 taps to the agency on the
21st. Um so we sat with them uh about
two weeks ago and we walked them through
this is our plan for because now that
this plan had been released we can share
with them hey this is what how we're
going to tackle this tap this tap this
tap this tap all the way through all 24
of them. We got feedback um on how to
refine the plan things to consider but
there was nothing in that meeting that
made me feel as though what we would be
submitting would be um declined. Uh but
to if something were to change, let's
say we got feedback, I told the agency,
I would love to get this feedback within
a week or two. Like you can wait 45
days, but you know, you know, we're
trying to do hard work here, like give
me a week, tell me as quickly as
possible, and then let me understand
what adjustments we need to make. Um, so
if there was a uh a decline, though I
wouldn't expect it. I would think it'd
have to do with proportionality of
students, you know, in movement, maybe,
you know, there's a some where they've
said, well, 51% of students go here,
then that's where the tap gets assigned.
We don't have anything that close, but
maybe there's a concern around something
like that. We would come back, we make
adjustments, but that's how it would
work. Uh, and I and I will just say, um,
we do not want to be in a place where
you submit a plan that, you know, will
get rejected. Uh, they know what they
want to see. We know, they know that we
know what they want to see and if we
submitted something that wasn't in
alignment, um, it would be viewed a
certain way. That's for sure.
>> Mr. Matias, I have a lot of questions
for you. I'm going to start in my
language because I'm a Spanish speaker
and I see I'm the minority here.
Okay.
Okay,
Matias.
Um, Mr. Matias, you had mentioned you've
said we a lot and as you say we
>> as as we say we um I don't see a lot.
>> This one's off.
>> Okay.
>> I don't I don't have anything on me. No,
it's back there. Um I don't see that we
in our community. Um and when I
my community. Um, we are not in
agreement, but we're outside. We're not
in here with with you all. And I just
want to know what you're going to do
about that.
>> So, um, I'll just I can talk about
>> what we're reporting.
>> Okay. Okay. Um, so we are wanting to
engage. We we have we will be present.
We'll continue to be present. Our
trustees have that expectation. they
themselves engage. So if there is a
place that we need to go um to to get
feedback from our community that we're
not currently going to, please let us
know. But we have asked to partner with
our school to have this space. If there
are spaces that we need to have moving
forward, I'm happy to have it. If we
need to go have um you know a meeting at
a restaurant, I'm happy to do that as
well. I I I hope that you know we will
show up. Um I also want to communicate
this is a large plan. lots of
communities are being impacted and so uh
I I know that oftentimes not everybody
can be everywhere at once, but if
there's a place that you believe we
should go to get feedback, please let us
know. We felt as though working with
Martin Middle School and bringing
families in the community into Martin
would be a good starting point. Um but
happy to make adjustments if we need to
move forward.
What's
Foreign
Um, sorry, this is not the first time
I've asked this, but um, I am going to
ask again directly. Um, as a parent, I
feel like it would be hard to get
involved. Um, I I am a parent of three
students, two that have already
graduated and I still have a student.
So, as a parent, if I don't feel
welcome, if I don't feel respected, it's
going to be really hard to show up. um I
I don't feel like I will be listened to
and um I'm sure that you're tired of of
my my asking of this, but as a district,
you have to work on on empathy for every
person that is working here so that we
all feel like we're we're welcome.
Okay.
Um, and I know I can't generalize with
everyone. Um, I know that there are many
kind and and and personnel and there are
those that are just as convicted as we
are to work with parents and students.
Um, but I just I do think that we're
missing support um and the values and
and the respect that we deserve.
>> So, um, first off, I'm I'm very sorry
that you feel this way. That's not what
I would want any family, any parent, any
guardian in Austin IC to feel ever. Um,
you know, I
I have been trying very hard for the
last two and a half years to build a
trustbased culture, a culture that
understands who we are as a city and
leans into all of us, right? whether you
know you have parents that work multiple
jobs, whether your lived experience is
different than than mine, it doesn't
matter. Like we should be there for our
families. Um, now I want to also
acknowledge that it hasn't always been
the case. You know, in years past, it's
been um it hasn't been a trustbased
culture. To get there requires a having
great principles. It requires making
sure that we have direct lines of
communication. It requires feedback
loops so that we're constantly engaging
and also uh resources to support um what
some schools can't have that other
schools do have. And we acknowledge that
that is an area of improvement. Um but I
want you to know that is what you're
describing um is is hard for me to hear
because
that's the last thing I want in this
school system is for any parent to feel
disrespected. Um there's a lot of work
to do. It's a large system. We've been
here for 144 years, but we're working on
it. Uh you know, I I hope that you found
at least some improvement as we
stabilized the last couple years. It
takes time, but we're happy to to make
adjustments and refine as we move
forward. But I agree with you, we're not
there yet. Um and it it's a large system
with over 70,000 students. You know, it
takes time, but I I agree with you. It
is an area that we need to focus on
before for
I padres.
for
Riverside
High School.
Does the river
Um, one one of the reasons that
Sorry. Um, so one of the reasons that
this is important and that I think so
many parents aren't here, but they're
they're fighting on the outside is
because they feel they're opposed to
this, um, and I'm not necessarily
opposed to this, but it really is a
disadvantage sending, um, my my my
children to other schools. Um, and maybe
it's because now they will have to take
the bus because of the zone changes and
they'll be less than a mile from a
school. But do you know what it's like
to live and walk on Riverside? These are
the projects to go from Riverside to Old
Torf. They're going to have to go past
homeless. There's so many traffic
accidents. Um, and I don't know if I'll
be able to get them a ride, but I don't
think they'll qualify for the bus. And I
do have a car, but I also have to work
and so I can't take them to school every
day. And that really concerns me.
>> Um, I can speak on this a little bit.
So, I'm I'm not sure exactly where you
live, but our Riverside boundary and if
you can go back to it, Ally, um if if we
would always give a bus, especially if
you're if it your student would be zoned
to Travis and they would have to cross
I35, that would be a hazardous route.
And so, we that's just our policy. We
would always give any student that's
considered a hazardous route or if
there's, you know, transient
populations. And so, that's something
that we would always provide any student
in in that type of scenario.
Thank you.
This changes
I know what she said, but you are
Okay. Um, so
you you well, first off, um, because
your students already at East Side Early
College High School, they will be able
to continue through East Side Early
College High School. Uh, one of the
things that we acknowledge is that we
need to have clearer um, transfer uh,
and transition plan language in our
plan. And so you're going to see that as
we develop a new draft as we finalize
the draft. Uh I also want to acknowledge
the disruption that it causes because
you were you know your student was
receiving transportation uh and now if
they're transferring it may look
different and this is the type of
feedback that we need to understand so
that we can make adjustments. We do not
want to make it more difficult than it
has to be on families as we move through
the transition. We are taking input to
make adjustments so the transition can
be done. uh in a in a healthy most
loving way possible, but I also know
it's going to be a disruption. Um so
that feedback is helpful. We are making
adjustments to our our um transfer
policies, our transition transportation
uh standard operating procedures because
I want to make sure that we acknowledge
that there is movement and we do
whatever we can to create as few
disruptions as possible. Um so that is
feedback that we're taking back and we
are trying to address it as best we can.
Well, thank you for this opportunity.
Um,
I do I'm really concerned about like the
teachers. Um, I understand the budget
deficit and I understand the state
accountability, but I kind of want to
focus on like locally.
I do agree that superintendent, school
districts are kind of coerced into
making this decisions to maintain like
local control.
Um, yeah, I'm concerned about the
teachers. It's really demoralizing that
construction has stopped and um the the
teacher or the principal at the next
school has the authority, but based off
of what? Do they have the right to
return here?
Um I guess that's my question for now.
Um so I I want everybody because there's
been some people that have said things
on Facebook or whatever that we're going
to, you know, release 700 teachers like
that. To be clear, that is not
happening. We've never said that. We
would never agree. We would never even
propose that. There have also been
people that have said, "Well, Matias is
looking at one year, two year,
three-year contracts." That never even
entered my mind until someone posted it
on Facebook. So, that is not how we
think. That is not who we are. Um, I
desperately wanted to share with our
community and to our staff more
importantly that we had built out a
transition plan for our staff that was
thoughtful but also recognize that each
scenario is different. If you have a
turnaround plan, there are requirements
that are not of the district but of the
state that we have to meet and many of
our educators have these designations
and we'll be able to facilitate that and
place them and ensure that they have um
a home in Austin ISD. We have
programmatic moves. You know, an example
of this would be um Becker to Sanchos.
Well, you know, again, we want to have
our students feel like it's their home.
It's their school. So, you want familiar
faces. So that is a different type of
staffing plan. We have a process for
that. We also have processes for
turnaround plans where the school that
is the receiving school um has not
historically struggled with
accountability. And this is one of those
instances that is a little bit more
challenging because from the state's
perspective, if that school has had an A
and A an A or B and B, a B, let them
keep doing their thing. Give them the um
uh responsibility of hiring. But we have
the responsibility of hiring. So, it's
important that we work with those
principles uh not only in the
transition, and I've met with all the
principles that are going through the
transition, and I've said to them over
and over again, we protect staff. We
protect staff, we protect staff. Um, we
are freezing outside hires. We're not
hiring anybody external to Austin ISD
until we are very far down this process.
Um, and I'm also want to be really clear
like we are releasing surveys to
understand what our educators want.
There are some educators who've told me,
even principles have told me, Matias,
I've been here for 15 years, but I live
up north. I'd like to actually find a
school closer to to North Austin. Like,
all those things are helpful. We're
working through them. I do not want a
single educator um in this district to
think that they are not centered as as
part of this work. They very much are.
Um I it's an expectation of mine, our
trustee, certainly of me. Um there are
details to be worked out, but and we're
actually going to be refining and
updating our plans. Um, but that is how
we plan to do this. We hire between 550
and 700 teachers every year, right? So,
people ask, "Well, the math doesn't work
out. Math doesn't work out." It actually
does work out. Um, just look at our
numbers. It doesn't necessarily mean
that you'll get to be at your campus.
Now, we're going to the campus that
receiving most of the students. We're
going to work through that. That's our
desire, but you're right. There'll be
some adjustments. Whatever adjustment
occurs, we're going to be doing it very
very thoughtfully. Um, I just I I need
to be really clear. That is not
something we've ever said. it is not
true and if anybody says it, please
please tell them that's not who we are.
Um, if the state came in, if anybody
else came in, all that goes out the
window. Um, so I I just want to be
really really clear because I that
that's frustrating to hear that because
that's never something we've ever said.
>> I don't know if that was helpful. Sorry.
>> And I just want to show folks so if
you're familiar with our consolidation
web page, it's just
austinisc.orgconolidate.
There's several um extra areas you can
explore over here, but if you click the
resources one on the side, it brings up
all of these resources we have. This is
where you can find that staffing
guideline that I talked about. Um it's
in English and Spanish. It's been shared
directly with all Austin ITD staff. Um
and it just explains kind of those
different scenarios. This is the
timeline that Matias was talking about
how we're going to freeze hiring and try
to find a place for all of our people
before we even think about recruiting
externally. Um, and then it talks about
the different types of consolidations
and then there's corresponding kind of
guidelines for each of those. So, I just
wanted y'all to see where you can find
that.
>> Oh, right. And thank you. This is I want
to introduce you, Brandy, and you can do
it.
>> Hi, I'm Brandy. I'm the talent strategy
officer for the district.
>> And she wanted me to share that um her
team has been going around. So to every
school that would be affected by a
consolidation that's proposed at this
point um her team has been going around
and talking going through this guide
these guidelines with them under letting
them understand what their options will
be talking about that interest survey
that they'll be doing um so that they
get the support that they need.
>> All right. Um I'm going to go here and
then next to you and then to you.
>> Hello. So, um I'm just looking at the
TAP plan. So,
you're moving students from um a school
with a F rating to two schools with a D
rating and you're also approaching like
the max enrollment from what I
understand. So like what are your plans
to help the new schools like um
uh control for this extra stress because
it's like the max enrollment and so all
the stresses with that.
>> Yeah, great question. So um so I want to
be so so we are track so great question.
Um so we are tracking uh all the
percentages um you know that the Texas
education agency builds the turnaround
plans based off assignment right so we
have to assume u based on where the
students live that this percent will go
to this school right in this case it'll
be keing for the majority um but we also
know that you know we also understand
your transfer rates we also understand
transfer rates of all the other schools
we we have an understanding of what the
final capacities the final utilizations
will be at these campuses. But you're
absolutely right. You know, one example
is General Marshall. General Marshall
has a D this year, but we also know kind
of this is the third year in in a
startup of a six, seven, and eight. And
we just talked about that when you start
up a new school, it's very very
difficult to get accountability kind of
where the state expects that quickly.
So, yes, they have a D, but they've been
working. We understand what Jordan, Dr.
Principson's doing over there, uh that
this this campus is stabilizing, is
moving in the right direction. And so we
have extreme confidence that though it's
a D now um it is moving in the right
direction but we are going to provide
additional resources. Our plan is so
much more detailed than what the state
requires. So the TAP plan is very kind
of distilled down. It's like you got to
do these things these things these
things. Our plan is much more detailed,
much more nuanced. And the last thing
I'll add is I want our families to know
that just because you're a D school or
whatever letter grade doesn't mean that
you're less than. Like just I just be
really really clear about that because
I've had people tell me, "Well, Matias,
their school is a D." And I'm like,
"Well, they were a B last year and we
just spent two years arguing around why
the accountability system doesn't work
and then now you're using that to argue
against me why this move shouldn't
happen." Like there are great things
happening in all of our schools,
including Martin. The reality is that I
still have to navigate this state, you
know, accountability system. And so we
are going to provide additional
resources not not just at the tap
schools but also at the schools that are
receiving the majority of students or
large percentages of students. I will
say however if there is a some split um
you know I can think of the middle
school that where the small percent is
going to a school uh in that case you
probably wouldn't see the same level of
adjustment from a resource perspective
because it's a minority in a population.
Um so that's how we're going to tackle
it. Uh but we also will be providing
additional resources which is also
somewhat laid out in the staffing plan.
Thank you. Uh hello everybody. My name
is Mrs. Sa. I'm a bilingual social
worker here at Martin School. I have
spent 14 years before I went to Nevada.
Um so I went to Nevada for a year and a
half and came back to Martin. So I've
been working with families for so many
years. I have seen transformation,
gentrification. I have seen demolishes
apartments on Riverside. I have seen
parents struggling to keep their
students and marching. I have seen
Mexican-Americans moving from this area
um telling their homes, you know. So, I
have leave with families and marching
with principles with assistant
principles working with Dr. Garcia back
in the day, assistant principles of
middle school, a very ethical and
hardworking man. Um so I have
experienced many things.
Parents are pivotal and decision making
and school transformation.
For me, not having the representation of
parents in this meeting, know as many as
we need it as partners are said. One of
the things that uh the parents said
about it, you know, where are the
representation
and your answer uh was that please give
the feedback. we're going to do tell us
where we need to go. So I thinking you
know when you do a presentation we do
data you know we bring reports we base
our outcomes on ba uh on data that we
have we map we strategize but why we
don't strategize to go where the parents
are
do we have an office that will say can
you please do a mapping and tell me
where Martin families live and we can go
where they are It's difficult for
families, Mr. Matias, to come to do some
meetings when they have to work daily.
It was back in the day, it's hard to
bring parents. But these rooms, this
library, if there were cameras and they
can talk, they will see we have 30 to 40
parents in meetings.
And I know that many parents are not
coming. You can put many excuses, you
know, immigrations, you know, but but
it's not that we all have to have the
passion and dedication and love to what
we do to bring those parents, you know,
because they sometimes don't know what
is happen in their schools and you know,
they might not speak the language. They
might not be able to maybe they work in
the evening, they cannot have the
virtual meetings. So you know compassion
and love for the families that have a
students here I have worked with with
teachers a lot of teachers I think Moses
and Mr. Cortez are the one they have
been longer and Martin
you know teachers are very dedicated
used to come at 6:30 7:00 in the morning
teachers will come and come to my office
we we uh do a lot of talking about what
we can do but and then another thing I
was thinking Mr. Matias, do we have in
the district a measuring tool to see the
performance of how we are doing with our
families? How do we do that? Do we just
have people to do this, do this, that,
but do we measure that? So, I really
encourage the district with the bottom
of my heart and the love that I have,
you know, that I have for families, you
know, employment retention, it's it's
people as well. Parents come and they
want to see Mr. Ramos has been forever.
Oh, Mr. Ramos is my my, you know, my
son. So, Mr. Garcia, I was the PH
teacher for so many years. So, you know,
this is because the success academic
success of a students depends a lot for
the parents.
Parents are important in the education
of the children because you come and I
tell parents you don't need to speak
English for your student to succeed.
They need discipline. They need
dedication. We have after school
programs. It's a lot of things. But if
they are not involved and they are not
coming and they don't know, Mr. Matias,
it's not something that they going to be
uh have priority on that. So, do we
measure how we welcome the parents? Do
we measure the parent involvement in
vision school? Are we going to be
mapping where they live? Back in the
days with Dr. Garcia will walk in those
building that were demolished and we
went where the parents were. You know,
we bring hot dogs when somebody one time
one of the apartments broke the second
floor uh where they walk. Parents were
crying because they will buy food and
they say, "Miss Arera, I had $200 of
food in that refrigerator. Now I don't
have access to to my um to my
apartment." So, we have to do the walk
where they are, not to bring them over
here. But just a suggestion, Mr. Matias,
and thank you for everything you do. and
transformation is pivotal and it's
important but we also need to have the
input of our families for they are what
they're going to be impacted. Thank you.
>> Thank you missa. And I just want to
share so we do have other opportunities
coming up for these conversations. Um,
I'll have to check the calendar, but
Martin will have every campus that's
going through these turnarounds will
have coffee with the principal, their
campus advisory council, and I'm happy
to work with your parent support here to
figure out if there are other spaces
that we need to be in um that can reach
more more families and get them involved
in this process. Additionally, when the
whatever package is ultimately voted on,
um
we are going to be standing up a team
that's going to help support the
transitions. And that's bringing the
school communities together, bringing
stakeholders from both school
communities to organize things like
you've said, like block walks to make
sure that folks know, for example, folks
around Sanchez that they know, hey,
Sanchez is still your school. You can we
want you to go to this school. um and
making sure that we do mailers so
families understand where their new
school assignment is. So, we'll have
teams stood up to kind of do that work
that you're talking about. And as far as
tracking, our parent support teams do
track um their attendance at the
different events that they hold. They do
surveys to see if families are finding
the opportunities beneficial. Um, and so
I will work more closely with your PS to
see what we can do to make sure we get
more parents involved in this kind of
decision-making process at Martin.
>> Uh, just very quickly, um, we have an
opportunity right now to move forward
with everything that we're doing. Um,
these incredible parents and community
members here, um, should be the starting
line for the conversation about what
needs to happen in a year or whatever it
may be. So, can I ask that we
immediately begin the conversations
right now and form a group that is
Martin? because as a alumni of Martin
Middle School and as a longtime member
of this community and the community as a
whole, I support our public schools, but
it is so important that we remember the
fact that these teachers that have put
their heart and soul into everything
that they do here. Um, as was mentioned
that there needs to be a right to return
because they have laid the groundwork
for a lot of things that have happened
here positive and as you point out these
letter grades that are placed on our
schools, these scarlet letters are
really
don't really show the great things that
are happening here. So, let this be day
one of the planning strategy for our
school here, our Martin Middle School,
our AISD Martin Middle School.
So, okay, I appreci appreciate that
comment. Um, and and we're and I that's
exactly what we want to happen. I I
think what I'm challenged with just
honestly is we're in the in between
phase right now. We are just like in
between. Uh we have, you know,
principles that are going through
transitions and they're ready to engage.
They they want to begin planning, you
know, uh what's, you know, what happens
in 26 27 uh as we um move through these
consolidations or TAP plans. So
everybody's ready to go, but this is
still a draft plan and we're still
getting feedback. Uh, and so I'm I'm
cautious. Like I I can commit to you
that's what we're going to do. I'm
cautious about doing anything before the
vote that is too concrete only because
the criticism that I'll get is Matias,
you the board the board hasn't even
voted yet. Why are you doing this? You
know, I just I mean Gab, you know it. I
mean, you see it. You sometimes you've
said it. I'm a seasoning, but but that's
that's kind of what's happening right
now. So, I I I want to start planning.
We want to put the folks together, begin
to get this work done. You know, I hope
our our community knows that, you know,
once we execute a plan and we get
something done, I will get it done. Uh
we're about to cross our fingers be out
of the TA agreed order before too long.
This is something two years ago we
thought was going to destroy AISD. Um
so, I just want you to know like we can
do difficult things. We can do them
together. I plan to do it with
community, not to community. We're just
at a very difficult moment right now
with all the things that we're
navigating. But yes, absolutely.
Bringing community together to plan what
the next um kind of vision of Martin
Middle School uh is is a priority for
us. And I'll tell you, as a part of our
trustees, you know, that that's some of
the feedback I've gotten directly from
them as well.
>> I know.
>> So, we have time for one or two more
questions and then I have a message from
some parents who couldn't be here that
we're going to read at the very end.
Sorry, I have a apologize if this
question like general question is not
appropriate for this forum, but um with
AISD enrollment already approaching like
really low levels, how do you expect
parents to um engage with the school and
school district if like the threat of
having their whole community like the
schools are it's now a possibility that
it can be just yanked away like closing
the schools and um having to integrate
their students into a whole new
community. Um at
>> Yeah. So,
so what I would say is um
so we're losing. So right now um we've
been on decline for a little while. It's
it's kind of began to balance out and
level out. And then what happened? The
federal administration stren uh you know
began to add more constraints around
immigration. So, we're seeing losses and
no new immigrant families coming in and
those that were here are leaving. So, I
just want to be really clear like this.
These are things that are happening
outside of of us and I'm having we are
having to respond. But I will also tell
you that I cannot right now pay for the
resources needed so that every student
who's been historically underserved gets
what they need to be successful. Period.
I mean, why I would argue why have for
the last 20 years families left the
neighborhood and chosen to go to Oh
Henry or chosen to go to the middle
school as opposed to Martin? Like I
would argue that if we actually have the
ability to pay for the resources and
ensure that it's equitable and we have
aligned feeder patterns like elsewhere,
then East Austin in my mind would
strengthen opposed to weaken and
families who are at charters will come
back. I mean because there are lots of
students in these charters who have
chosen to go to a different school
district, a different school. Why did
they do that?
Well, it's because there were decisions
that were made five years ago, 10 years
ago, 15 years ago that put us in
difficult position. But we cannot ask
families to come back unless we are
investing in our schools, moving
accountability because that right,
wrong, or indifferent when it comes down
to it at that dinner table when you're
comparing two schools, people will use
that letter grade. It is a started
letter, but it's they will use it
because I mean they don't know what we
know. We're like we're in the middle of
it, but a lot of families just go down
to a letter grade. I understand that.
So, we have to do two things. We have to
create the systems to be responsive to
the environment we're in. We have to
allocate resources to strengthen our
schools so that no matter where we are,
we're educating our way. And then when
the STAR summitive assessment is done,
we perform. But we're not training our
system to perform to be responsive only
to that test. We're responding to
educate our students in a way that
aligns with our values, which means we
got to keep our board in place, which
means we got to keep our team in place.
And then we take that assessment and
we're successful. And if you do that,
you have strong schools, strong
neighborhood schools that are well
resourced, you will draw students back.
There's no doubt. Um there will be
disruption. I acknowledge that. I'm
trying to account for it so that
families don't leave. Um and I don't
want people to think that it's been
yanked away. You know, like these are
things that, you know, are outside some
of our controls and I don't have lots of
options. I just don't. If I did, I would
explore them. I just honestly don't. Um,
so we're trying to find solutions that
address multiple things and position us
up, position us for success for the
next, you know, 50 years. Um, yes, year
one and two are important. Uh, but 50 is
really what we're we're trying to get
to,
>> right? This will be our last question.
>> Um, first I'm Rebecca. I work with AISD
and student support services. Um and I I
want to say first I appreciate the
passion today um that has come during
this meeting. We I think a lot of us in
this room get very passionate when we
speak from time to time uh especially
concerning these things. And so I
appreciate the passion that has come
through your voice today to see that you
are angry as well. Right. I'm just going
to say angry because that that's how we
feel, right? Um I attended Johnston and
Porter which are now closed and um with
the multiple proposals going on I
support a grant a supervisor grant that
we have from DOE for Martin Allison and
Go Valley of which would all be no more
grant right if things continue to get
approved with the way that they are
because Allison would leave the vertical
team and the grants for the vertical
team go valley would be repurposed and
Martin right looking at our options with
Martin. So, one for me on a grant level
that's man that's $2.5 million. It's a
5-year grant that we are at risk of
losing because our campuses would no
longer serve the narrative of the grant.
That's a whole another separate issue
with a lot of other things going on and
I don't expect a response to that. Just
throwing that out there since we're all
taking notes on things that are going on
on our campuses as these changes are
happening, right? Um, in addition to
that, uh, I think about how we're going
to continue to support enrollment at
East Side, right? because watching
Johnston and going through Johnston
closing and then watching what's
happening as we divide to support a lot
of things and I see the good in where
y'all are coming from and the decisions
you're having to make. I do um but I
also think man how are we going to
support enrollment at East Side, right?
How are we going to support East Side
now? Um because we have a a memory hall
there, Johnson does. It's cute. Um the
other part of that is our grant works
with wraparound services, right? My
experience is clearly not at the
district level transformation
uh experience level. I'm I'm experienced
with campus level transformation right
in the classrooms in at the small table
in the groups right so I'm thinking like
many of us and I've heard voice today
those those schools receiving our
students you know having been a teacher
with multiple learning levels in one
classroom and we're talking about some
students on grade level because we are
making progress and we're on trajectory
to get out of D right now I've got some
babies that are three grade levels below
and we are in a deficit and we don't
have more staff yet right we're not
there yet. So, how can we continue to
support and how do we be a part of that?
Those of us who are experienced with
that or want to continue to support the
student so that they feel supported and
our teachers. We don't want to lose the
amazing teachers at our schools
receiving these students who do it from
their heart as well. Right? So to me
it's are we growing the MTSS department
because we all know that MTSS is a huge
part of not only what's mandated but
what works and how are we going to
continue to support that piece of the
transition. Um and then the wraparound
services that we have contracts with
with our service providers that we know
are are happening at these campuses. We
supervise Allison Go Valley Martin
specifically to know how many families
are getting rental assistance and
support services through CIS and Austin
Voices and TRIO. Do those contracts
continue to get renewed and somehow
continue to be provided? Because
although we're going to provide, you
know, Daisy's Children Transportation,
people still need rental assistance,
right? And they still need the food
pantries, Ryder Bites does amazing work
at Allison for that community. if
Allison moves to a vertical. I know this
is a different subject, but I'm just
thinking those things.
>> Yeah. So,
so this is um I appreciate the question
because one of the things that I've uh
asked our trustees and our community to
consider is how important the November
timeline is. You know, we need to be
thinking about transition. We need to be
thinking about all the things you
brought up, whether it's grants have to
be negotiated, whether resources have to
be deployed. The worst thing we can do
honestly is to delay a vote that has our
future like stability of the
organization like in it. Um one month
you know I think I've heard committee
Matias why don't you delay till
December. Well when you think about
enrollment the enrollment process starts
in November. You think about you know
hiring of principles. We said there
we're going to hire principles in
December. This vote doesn't take place
in December. Now I'm hiring principles
in January. the enrollment system and
the enrollment process is know all of
December, all of January, all of
February into March. If I lose one of
those months now I have three months.
I've lost 25% of the time needed to
actually make the improvements. Y'all
know how frustrating a rolling can be.
It's not because we make it hard. It's
because we have to get partners to
actually do the coding to improve the
system. That takes time. And what I
don't want to do is to fail on
execution. Like I want to get to a place
where we can take a vote, understand
that there's an urgency around it
because of the environment we're in, and
then spend time planning, planning,
planning, planning, the grants, student
movement, staff movement, the resources
I need to deploy to make sure that
transitions occur in a in a very
thoughtful way, whether it's
transportation or otherwise. Like, if we
lose time in the spring semester, then
we will start the 2627 school year and
be out of position to be successful.
That's just the honest truth. And I I I
will not support that. We either take it
on or or you know or that we don't and
then you know who knows what happens.
But I I just want you to know because we
you remember sixth grade got taken out
of Martin in April. Think about how long
that took to recover. We didn't even
recover from it. I would argue that some
of the elementary schools in the area
who were impacted adversely from an
accountability perspective struggled
because they had the sixth grade at
those campuses. But we did that in the
late spring. We were scrambling like
crazy to try to get that to work and it
never ultimately took root. You cannot
do that to people. You cannot do it and
I'm not going to do it. So, um I'm
committed to not making those decisions
in the spring. The one thing we cannot
take away is time for families to plan.
Uh so your questions around grant, yes,
if we know what we're doing, then we can
have those conversations. We can work
with Michelle Wallace and OID. We can
figure out if there's opportunity to
renegotiate those contracts. Um, I would
argue and I'd make a strong argument
that students are students and that, you
know, just because we change the feeder
pattern or, you know, we can figure out
what that looks like. I will tell you
that you'll see me be supportive of any
decision that keeps resources deployed
where they originally intended. Um,
school specific. Uh, I I don't that's
that's what they were intended for. Um,
feeder pattern, that's us like we do
that. Um, so I just want you to know
that that's what I keep hearing and I
you know I think your point's an
important one and I wanted to make sure
that everybody understood why November
is important. Um, we will we will fail
or I won't we won't say I'll fail. I
will say on the execution side we will
do harm more harm if we don't have
appropriate time to plan and transition.
Who it was you know Gib we're talking
right here about getting the Martin
community to talk about beginning a plan
for a new school. Well, you lose a whole
month or you're not going to start until
after the vote takes place, honestly.
And then you're in the holiday break.
So, you're probably starting January. I
just want to be really really clear like
time it does it seems like it's really
far away, but we start planning for the
school year for next year already. Like
that's happening now.
>> Thank you so much. I do have uh some
remarks from a parent that they wanted
me to read, but I'm going to real quick
just as a reminder. Don't know why this
is zoomed out, but um so this is our
timeline. I've mentioned already we're
in this phase right now of having we
have the digital participation. You have
the QR code on the back of your seats.
Um so plenty of time to still get that
in by the 28th. We also have the
meetings coming up. If you go to
austinisd.org/conolidate,
/consolidate, you'll see the remaining
um community meetings that are happening
both districtwide as well as all of the
schools that are also having
conversations like these. So, if you go
to one, bring someone next time um so we
can get more folks involved. Um November
6 is that date that I shared that the
board will be discussing the revised
version of this plan and that will go
public on October 31st. Um, and then
that November 20th is the vote and it's
cut off on the screen for some reason,
but the consolidations wouldn't take
effect. We just wanted to make sure it
was really clear until next school year.
We would have that vote in November, but
this as Matias was saying or
superintendent, we want this whole rest
of this school year to plan so that we
can have a successful launch of the next
school year. Um, and this is that QR
code to the comment card, the website,
the resources that I shared where you'll
find that staffing guide. Um, and
there's also what we call a story map
that is kind of a visualization of kind
of all of the proposals across the
district. Um, and kind of how we reach
those decisions. So, lots of resources
austinisd.org/conolidate
where you can find all of this. Um, and
with that, I'm going to go ahead and
just read the remarks that this parent
shared with me. Um, so it's addressed to
you, Mr. Sigura. Um, to the principal
and the school community. Good morning.
Thank you for this opportunity to
discuss this with respect and open
heart. Mr. Sigura, we know your
experience comes from the field of civil
engineering, an area that seeks to build
strong, safe, and lasting structures,
and that is valuable. But today, we want
to remind you that education is the
foundation of all buildings, even those
that you have helped build yourself. We
remember some words that you mentioned
at one point. Many changes can weaken
structures or cause them to collapse. We
have taken your words to heart.
Education is a structure. Without
education, there are no engineers, no
architects, no leaders or strong
communities. A society without education
collapses, no matter how solid its
buildings are. We understand that the
district faces financial challenges and
structural challenges. But when we talk
about closing or consolidating schools,
we're deciding more than the fate of a
building. We're deciding the future of
children, families, and an entire
community. We take up another phrase you
mentioned. We must integrate as a
community to create a strong education
system. As an integrated community, we
know that a school is not just a set of
walls. It is the heart of a
neighborhood, the place where children
feel safe, where parents find support,
and where families grow together.
Closing a school is like breaking a bond
that took years to build. And even with
technical arguments, the human damage
can be measured in numbers. Structures
can be rebuilt, budgets can be adjusted,
but a generation that loses access to a
closed quality education doesn't recover
so easily. Therefore, we ask that before
making decisions that produce a collapse
within Austin ISD, we look beyond the
plans and numbers. May the voices of
students, teachers, and families who
live within these schools every day be
heard. May it be remembered that an
educated community can build any
structure, but a structure without the
participation of the entire community
and without education remains empty,
soulless, and without purpose.
Education is not an expense. It is an
investment. It is the greatest,
strongest, and most lasting construction
society can leave behind. Education is
non-negotiable. We educate ourselves to
learn how to negotiate. We educate new
generations so they can resolve
conflicts, find arguments, and improve
the world without destroying it. Thank
you for listening to us and for your
willingness to be here with us. We hope
this conversation is not just about
buildings, but about people, dreams, and
futures, because that is where progress
is truly measured.
Um
>> no I appreciate uh closing with that um
that letter. What I what I will tell you
is um yes my background years and years
ago was engineering and then it became
finance and then it became you know
operations. Uh then it became, you know,
really a focus on how to support large
systems, large public education systems
to allocate the resources to where
they're needed most. Like that's end of
the day, if you go back generations,
that's been the challenge. How come
black and brown students have not been
resourced in the same way um or been
resourced to meet the needs uh decades
ago that they are now? Like why did that
happen? I mean in and what decisions
were made at that point.
So, uh, yes, my background is
non-traditional, um, but I am a systems
person and I want people to know that
over the last two and a half years,
we've done an incredible amount of work
that this community, all communities in
Austin should be very proud of. Whether
it's navigating the TA grade order,
whether it's implementing MTSS,
multi-ter system of support, so for the
first time, we have an understanding of
where all of our students are, whether
it's us, you know, getting to an aligned
curriculum. You know, I want to be
really honest. We had, you know, 15 16
different curriculum being run within
all of our schools. What do you think
that hurts? It it hurts the students who
have high mobility rates. When you go
from one school where you're one scope
in sequence, you go to another school, a
different scope in sequence, and the
staff is trying to figure out where
they're coming from and what they need.
It it's just it's a system that was
designed to produce the outcomes we
have. And the outcomes we have are that
schools in certain parts of town have
been underresourced. And because of
that, over years have gotten to a point
where it's been difficult for them to
break the accountability chain. This is
not a band-aid solution. It has to be
something comprehensive because we're at
a moment where only a comprehensive
change will work. Um, I intended to
bring things together that allow us to
address as I talked about transfers and
consolid and budgets and program
stability and aligned feeder patterns.
We would have never ever taken on feeder
patterns unless it was all tied
together. Think about that. In 20 years,
when you look back, I would argue that
one of the most profound things that
this planet will have done will have
lined feeder patterns. I mean, why is it
that when you go to Anderson High
School, you know, all the students that
are at MKAN are wearing Trojan hats and
you come to Martin, you go to, you know,
Mendees, you go to schools like there's
four or five high schools, you break up
community, that's just not we can't do
that. We can't do it. So, um, I just
want you to know that I appreciate you.
Uh, we are at a time where there's
immense disruption. I'm trying to be
responsive to all the risks that we're
navigating. Keeping local control is
absolutely a priority of mine. You know,
being responsible for educating our our
students is something I take like I give
my life to it. I mean, I really do. Um,
and we're going to take this input.
We're going to refine. We're going to
improve. Uh, and we'll take the next
step together. So, I appreciate all of
y'all. Uh, you know, these these
meetings matter. Uh, we take the
feedback. We'll adjust. Um, and I
appreciate all of y'all spending time
with me this morning. So, thank you.